y hacen cuanto a las medidas sanitarias
5000 personas pueden venir aquí todos
los días al menos hasta el 9 de junio y
a partir de esa fecha serán 15.000
espectadores por eso también el torneo
pues comenzó una semana más tarde de lo
que tenía programado cada persona para
venir aquí tiene que mostrar un test
negativo o demostrar que ya ha recibido
la vacunación la vacuna contra el
alcohol y 19 en cuanto a los temas
deportivos bueno usted lo decía el big
free este regreso tanto de roger federer
rafael nadal y novak djokovic que los
tres estén en este en este torneo esto
no sucedía desde hace dos años por
supuesto rafael nadal siempre es y sigue
siendo el favorito no solamente entre
estos tres grandes tenistas sino en
realidad en el cuadro masculino podría
convertirse pues en el jugador que más
grand slams ha ganado en todo caso por
la parte de los hombres si logra
conseguir esa esa corona número 14 pero
bueno también hay estos jugadores
jóvenes como dominique team que ya ha
estado en dos ocasiones en la final y
también stefano sí sí para es el griego
quien también ha venido haciendo una
buena temporada por el cuadro femenino
pues está por supuesto arriba
es una de las grandes favoritas es la
número uno mundial pero está también
gigas baitec esta es la polonesa que
justamente estará de cumpleaños el día
de mañana cumpliendo 20 años y quien
viene a defender el título que consiguió
aquí en octubre de 2020 estará por
supuesto novio zac a quien justamente ya
es entró en liza el día de hoy que es
una de las grandes aspirantes y digamos
que un poco como siempre pues está la
reina de roland garros esta es serena
williams la estadounidense que bueno va
a volver a intentar conseguir un nuevo
título aquí para poder igualar ese
récord de margaret court de 24 grand
slams algo que todavía le ha sido muy
esquivo